uh call the meeting back to order
um and uh i see that mary you
you were asking some questions so um
i would like you to ask the question
again so i can join in thank you i'm
sorry
oh no i'd be happy to so um as i said
um when the governor was here that when
i was at snoo
um the uh board of uh the executives
um they invested
multi multi-million dollars into
the design my concern right now
is that there is no line
item for this merger and i think if
we're going to
do something of this magnitude
that we need to plan thoughtfully and
there need to
there really needs to be designated
dollars for this purpose
i mean we have to run the ship two ships
big ships
and we have to figure out how to build a
bigger ship
and to do that you need to invest in it
and be able to have people that can help
with the planning
the redesign and that that's my big
concern i
i have not seen that any money has been
invested in that
thank you
uh susan do you want to comment on that
yes i'd like to comment on that and and
perhaps one other thing if that's okay
um we raised that question to the
governor's office
and there was an indication that they
would look for funds
potentially from the you know money
coming with the pandemic but there's
been no
indication and i agree you know we have
um
a synergies group that consists of i
co-chair with jackie eastwood
who's one of the university system
trustees and our whole purpose
we've been meeting since early summer
has been to identify
synergies and so for example
we are all on the same learning
management system contract
now and by doing that the community
college system was able to save two
hundred thousand dollars
and we're looking at insurance and and
transfer pathways and there's been a lot
of conversation but
to your immediate question we don't
really know where the money would come
from
and if i may yeah let me let me just
follow up on that if i could
um when you say
uh looking for uh money
what are you looking for to
employ or to um
come to grips with are you thinking
about a consulting firm
or i i'm just you know yeah
asking um
a lot of speculation perhaps it's a
consulting firm perhaps other people i
mean i was
i'm concerned for instance um
are we going to have some educators that
are involved in creating
this merger um there are financial
issues which people were talking about
but some of the other things that the
governor was talking about like
transfer and i would raise accreditation
uh financial aid uh unions
benefits and so on we probably will need
consultants and i guess the
the best comparison for me is you know
the bea
wanted to look at their economic
development centers and a better model
and so the state gave money for that
dhhs was reorganizing and there was
money that was devoted to that to
you know potentially it is to bring in a
consulting firm i i don't have
the specific idea i mean we as we shared
with you this morning
um did an examination of
the various mergers that have happened
across 20 states
and so it is going to take expertise
to you know figure this out
sorry go ahead with your other comment
my other comment is i have a different
uh recollection of the lpn program
and how that came to be um that i would
like to share and that is that
some of you may know i for the previous
governor chaired her governor's
uh work uh commission on
the health care workforce and one of the
things that came out of that
loud and clear was the need for lpns
we went out of the lpn business as a
system
because they were not getting jobs and
in fact there was a
short period of time where even our rns
were having difficulty
when i talked to the various presidents
about uh whether their
students are getting hired they were
getting hired on a per diem
situation which is not ideal if
somebody's graduating from college you
want them
sitting in a full and permanent uh
position
that was short-lived and life is
different now
but i bring this up because um we
started to listen to the healthcare
sector partnership initiative
specifically the monadnock region was
really
uh leading the whole cry for the need
for lpns
and so as part of our budget proposal at
that point
we asked for one-time funding and and my
recollection is when we asked for it
and we were asked how much money when we
went back and
and figured it out to the penny it was
641 000
something or other the governor's office
was was
pleased and somewhat amused that that's
what we thought because we figured it
out to the penny for us to get back into
that
business now there were lots of voices
at that time
so you know different recollections but
but i see it as yes we got out of that
business
because people weren't getting jobs uh
my nightmare as a president always was
you know
when we started to work with another big
project in the state
we knew they were going to need
technicians but until we knew exactly
what kind of technicians they needed
it wasn't appropriate to create the
program and and have students be in
it because you don't want people to get
to the end of a credential
and not have a job um and so
this is kind of akin to that situation
and representative umbergo thank you for
letting me
speak about that uh no problem susan i
was
uh i was surprised at the governor's
comments as well
but uh uh kathy would you like to say
something
about uh the suggestion on
consultants um thank you representative
umberger
um i'll put consultants aside for a
minute and
speak more about technology um the
the r in in my opinion
a big part of this would be a common
platform
so first of all the university system is
look if we're kind of in a discovery
phase if you will
thinking about bringing our
enterprise-wide technology for
student facing all the student systems
the accounting systems the hr systems
we're not using current technology and
it's disparate
so a benefit would really be to have
everyone on the same platform the same
student system
the same and that will take money
that will take an investment so you know
would you have to have a maybe a
consultant
implementer with that probably
i don't um i'll be honest i don't know
enough
susan's much more knowledgeable in the
areas of
accreditation and financial aid and that
would definitely have to be addressed
but
in in my thinking it would there would
be some
real technology needs that's how to make
this
really smooth so a student is
having the same experience on their
their student
and the student system across
all colleges and universities
go ahead i think
the canvas project right now is a great
example of exactly what kathy is talking
about
so because of the work of the university
system and the community college system
and the department of education
we now have one platform that can be
used all the way from kindergarten
through
graduate school and i frankly am really
excited about the opportunities because
now we've created a platform
that's going to make it easy for you
know a first grade class to invite a
professor
from university of new hampshire to come
in and talk about something
with the you know the great uh oceanic
work that they're doing
and so to kathy's point the technology
will cost money in the community college
system
five years ago we went to one student
management system and it's one
instance of the student management
system
the university system uh i'll let kathy
speak about that but that was a big
project for us so that
at this point we wanted to make it
easier for our students to transfer
within and among the community colleges
so
long answer to say i support what
kathy's saying
and the university system isn't there
with the one instance of student
we have multiple instances of student
so that's why i'm saying we're now in
the discovery phase
of how do we you know migrate in that
direction
but again if you could have it across
if there's to be one public higher
education system in new hampshire
the platform has to be consistent in my
opinion
i i certainly agree with that and i see
a lot of other
heads shaking so um okay uh
representative petrie i'm not sure
whether you were
representative bucco or next but whoever
was go ahead
please
uh represent petrie yeah you know
technical issues as usual uh thank you
for taking my question uh
well actually it's not a question that's
a comment uh
we built well we started with silos you
know the individual
colleges uh you know uh plymouth
university and then we came to the
university system
and we built another bureaucracy and
then we had chancellor's office
a few years ago we did a uh i believe
robbie parsons uh representative
probably 11 12 session
uh he did a he uh did his own study and
he
discovered that uh we could save about
41 million dollars by eliminating the
chancellor's office
um and now keeping the financials
together that of all all the university
uh
the whole what the university system is
now but is that what we're doing now is
building a
you know a bigger bureaucracy of putting
more people together
and more levels of bureaucracy
somebody could answer that
um so i would say
representative petry that
the the chancellor's office budget is
nowhere near 41 million dollars
so i'm not i remember representative
parsons well i worked with him for
many years when i was state treasurer
and then when i went to the university
system
so um i don't know about
layers of bureaucracy um
is it i can tell you what we're doing in
the university system right now though
is what i mentioned earlier about part
of this restructure
rather than having
folks all over the place at all of the
campuses
processing invoices for example we're
going to do that
centrally and have one
process that's understood by everyone
rather than disparate processes
could this consolidate or combination of
the two systems
have consolidated work
centrally yes i suppose that's that's
likely i think that would reduce costs
uh i don't i don't know about added
bureaucracy i guess
uh susan you go ahead please thank you
um our system office
really does the work of the colleges so
that we don't have duplication
um so we have our internal audit we have
our the
the system office has does all of the
negotiating
uh does all of the work on benefits you
know are there people on the campuses
that
support and feed some of the information
of the chancellor's office yes but
the work that happens isn't
if we didn't do it at the system office
it would have to happen on the campuses
on the colleges and that to me would
make it more expensive and
would create situations where you know
some of our colleges don't need much
legal assistance at any one time and
sometimes some of the colleges need more
legal assistance
the fact that that comes out of the the
chancellor's office makes it a more
efficient use of
resources the cost for the
chancellor's office and the community
college system
salaries and everything in is less than
10 million dollars not that i think
that's a
small number and i agree with kathy
there there are opportunities here
uh for bringing some functions together
i i support that um we're we are doing
some of that work already where for
instance
um white mountains and nhti share some
financial aid services so that
we're not uh you know bringing in more
people than we need
uh but you know there's opportunities
and i i
i think i would say we hear you loud and
clear that while we may be doing that
work we need to move a little faster at
it
and we're certainly willing to do that
and and we have a willing partner in the
university system
and and to follow up on on susan's
comments
representative petrie the the system
office
at the university system does the same
kind of work
as far as internal audit general counsel
hr employee relations
um accounting
a number of of administ back office or
administrative type work
for all of the campuses
thank you uh representative bucco would
you
like to go ahead please um oh okay
thank you madam chair am i i'm not muted
so so this question is for the vice
chancellor for finance at the university
system
and i'm i'm referring to this page that
you had highlighted
um so
for the for the two for the two years
fiscal 22 in fiscal 23
um the governor's budget recommends 166
million
uh no that's not correct i'm i'm sorry
i'm getting that wrong
for the two for both the university and
the community college it's 138 million
right
that's for both of them that's right so
and so um
i'm trying to arrive at how much money
is actually being taken out of this
education system to be or
not put someplace else but it in the
governor's
in the governor's budget um
the actual expense was for for fiscal
year 2020 was 151.7 million
and if you subtract 138 million out of
that
it's already 13.7 million less
am i am i getting that correct or i mean
it looks like it's about 23 million
dollars less
for both of those things so so i would
just caution you that
in fiscal year 20
the university system was um
appropriated
one time dollars of nine million so if
you take that
out of the mix because we recognize that
was one time
the the let's look at it this way let's
say
um i hate to look at it this way because
again if we're going to be one system
but let's just say the so the university
system is
uh is um there's a four and a half
million dollar reduction
from the current level in year one
and then there's a two million dollar
reduction in total
in year two right
in in total across the two systems okay
so um you know
comb i'm going back to fiscal 21
is it 88.5 million dollars and we
and the the university system requested
flat in 22 and 23.
yes but there's over over the two years
that's
a six a six and a half million dollar
reduction right if you allocated
the 2 million and 23
to the university system if if there
were two
systems still in existence i feel like
i'm confusing the issue
i'm sorry i probably did but but i was i
was just trying to
i um
reduction there is
there is definitely a reduction
to public higher education
in house bill 1 compared to the last
biennium
would it be helpful representative or
kathy or madam chairman if we shared
screen quickly just to see the
governor's budget request
just to exactly see the lines or do you
all have that
yeah you can share it up matthew
i've got it right here oh this is just
that this is just the university system
actually i think
i can share kathy i have the budget uh
pulled up
if it would help
you'd see that right yeah that's what i
was looking at
so to kathy's point about you know if we
pull out recognizing there was one time
money
uh in fiscal 20 and look at just
where both systems were in fiscal 21
you see one 143 860
down to 140 down to 138.
and and so so representative bucco
without
the the nine million dollar one-time
money in fiscal
20 the university systems that was at
85.5
right then then it went to 88.5 and 21.
to down to 84 in 22
and it will come down further in total
the total public higher ed appropriation
comes down
2 million in 23.
okay thank you
thank you matt uh
represent murray i know i see you have a
question
thank you very much i'll try to be quick
before i head off for my coffee shop
um i had i guess two things one it's i
do
agree with what i'm hearing a little bit
in terms of there's
needing to be some direction and some
planning before
you know going ahead with this it's not
like you take the two boards put them
together cut them in half and then
you're done
um i think there's an awful lot of back
story if you will
that we need to consider in terms of how
this affects how the university and the
college system runs and how it affects
the students
the other thing i'm concerned about
which i haven't heard us talk about yet
it's not financial
but the optics involved with this i
remember the disaster the debacle when
the art institute first initially tried
to merge with snoo
and no one was prepared no one knew
anything was going on where i was
actually in
athens in greece at the time with the
group of the photography students
and it just popped up no one knew and it
was they had to back down it was an
absolute um public relations mess up
and so it seems to me that there's an
educational and a marketing component in
going forward this because i think
students are going to have
they're going to care they're going to
care about the school that they're at
they're going to care about what that
means to what their degree is going to
look like what the thing is they're
going to hang up on the
bathroom wall or wherever you put all
your degrees um and i think you know
those human elements are also really
important to consider
in doing this i think that there's
opportunity here
i agree with the governor that we
probably don't need to study for five
years
but i think we need uh something a
little bit more than two line items in
the budget in order to plan this
to be successful so i prefer i'd be
interested
with susan and catherine your comments
on that and then forgive me when i
bug off i'm going to be heading out for
my shot
just a moment please matthew is your
comment related to what um
representative murray had to say or is
it something else
yes representative it is okay go ahead
then
and representative murray certainly
appreciate you know those comments
because i agree that there is a human
impact that
that we need to make sure um you know as
part of these conversations but
i think a lot of that runway uh
is already happened right we've already
had these conversations
with both systems to identify what that
path forward looks like
and the next logical step really is
to combine that governance structure and
then put empower
those decision makers to identify
what those next steps are and i think
you heard the governor speak to that
this morning that we we know
conceptually
where the economic pressures are but
also where the opportunities are for the
students
and by bringing the boards together
through this budget we see that as
again the the best path forward
for both of these systems and most
especially the students
and it's also why we're not going full
bore um
in year one right we do understand there
are going to be
longer structural changes that need to
happen
and that's why we've put this on a
two-year plan
as opposed to trying to make this all
happen here in the next
two or three months we certainly
understand that
a quick follow-up please go ahead
um in the spirit of all the stakeholders
being at the table
have you spoken to any students yet
i i believe that those conversations
have been ongoing
as budget director i haven't been
directly involved in that component but
i think
students understand that both from the
remote learning perspective that we've
had here
because of coven there's also going to
need to be those challenges because as a
student first and foremost
they want to be able to get from point a
to point b um and if we find ourselves
in a position where
uh we do suddenly appear to be in a
crisis you know five or ten years out
because we haven't taken action today um
there might be far worse consequences
for students
and that's what we're trying to avoid
right we're trying to move now
seeing the tidal wave that's coming our
way to do this strategically and on
purpose
as opposed to being forced into a
reactionary model
where we don't have time to get it right
we just need to avoid disaster
so that's the impetus behind having
these conversations now
looking at the data and we think that's
a better outcome for students than
waiting until it's too late
cathy do you have anything you want to
add
no only that i think you folks probably
have seen
um the university system board's
statement
that that our board is pretty unwavering
in their support
for moving forward recognizing that um
primarily because of the why recognizing
that there still needs to be work
and thought um with both community
college system and university system
people at the table on the how
susan do you have a comment
yes thank you i i ditto to everything
kathy
just said that there's work that needs
to be done
we haven't even talked about bringing in
not only student voices but also
faculty and and staff voices and
uh the voices of our business partners
the the one thing that i will also add
to that
is you know not only is there a
declining
number of high school graduates but when
we look at the graduates that we
currently have
only 30 percent of them have a plan
about going to college or to career and
so on
so we do have an opportunity as a state
to serve
not only the 70 of recent high school
graduates but
uh you know i also think about the older
students i mean
about almost half of our student body is
in fact people over the age of 25 who
find that they need education
so creating something that gives people
opportunity is absolutely important
i don't know if i would go so far as the
tidal wave i do think there's an urgency
but at the same time there are lots of
pieces to this this is not
bringing two very simple organizations
together so i would
um you know urge a timeline that also
includes uh the ability to look at at
all of these
of features i mean as the governor said
other people have done it
so frankly let's learn from what other
people have done
and go on thank you representative
okay thank you very much um ken were you
next or was joe next
i think i had my hand up excuse me
before
joe so anyway um
this is kind of a progressive thing uh
20 odd years ago i was on the higher
education study committee
when we discovered that two students
could be sitting side by side in a
community college english class
one is going to study to be an
engineering technician the other one's
studying to be a registered nurse and
the registered nurse could
credit that english class to getting an
rn in
unh but if the engineering tech
decided he wanted to go forward and get
an engineering degree he couldn't
credit the same class and we thought the
heck is going on and we did finally
straighten that out and got almost all
the courses transferable and i thought
that was a big deal
and we went forward with that but i'm
i'm worried about
corporate attitude if you will uh
chancellor ward
made a statement that i thought was very
telling
i'm not going to teach a course that's
not going to give them a job
and i think that's a wonderful attitude
to take that
you know well i didn't have lpn because
nobody was hiring lpns
made a lot of sense and you're looking
forward
for some of these students that can't
even look forward for themselves
but then i look at the unh system and
it's okay you can come here and
you know one of my fellow pilots years
ago had
graduated from unh with a degree in
irish history
fortunately he went in the marines and
learned to be a pilot and got him a good
job
and then he went to mit and got a phd in
astrophysics
but you know at the unh
it's all all well and good to just study
education for the
for the purpose of learning something
but you're going to go out with a
massive
debt load and a huge expense and if
that's not going to help you
if that degree isn't going to help you
pay for it there ought to be more
counseling within the unh to say so
really what do you want to do for a
living
and you realize how little that pays or
you realize
you know that there are no jobs for that
kind of thing
so i appreciate what the community
college does and i
hope they don't lose it when if and when
they merge with
unh because unh needs to get i think
more along the line of
what are you what are you learning what
do you aim to do with your life
and kind of give them a little more
direction when when they're studying
stuff that
won't get them a job but they'll
graduate with a massive debt load and
then maybe they'll renege
anyway that's that's my thought thank
you okay thank you representative weiler
excuse me i was eating a cookie and a
crumb went down my throat which is not
such a good idea representative petry go
ahead
thank you madam chair uh this is a
question for probably uh
ms preventure uh what is the total
budget of the university system that's
all revenue and all expenses
the total budget is about
800 million dollars
thank you
okay um are there any other questions
from
from the committee
i i have a couple of questions if i
could
excuse me um
this is dealing with the capital budget
i realized that um you know we don't
we in division two don't really have a
lot to do with the capital budget
but what are your capital
uh budget requirements uh for the next
two years and
what are the prospects of them being
funded
and are we
looking at are we looking at any of the
capital budget
items that we could make
tweaks to that would help to satisfy
some of the issues of
combining the two systems
either one i don't care who goes first
i i can go first so so in the last
in the last budget cycle two years ago
um the university system
received appropriation for three
biennium
similar to the keep program and so
and the governor has not changed that in
in house bill 25 is introduced so the
university system
has 15 million dollars over the two-year
period
the vast majority of that is to continue
to support
the biological sciences pro the largest
project the university system has ever
undertaken
um and the the state is providing about
a third of the total funding for that
project um i would guess that
it's highly unlikely that any of that
could be diverted
to dollars
for the proposed combination i can tell
you also that
that 15 million dollars super impactful
on the total university system capital
budget but our total capital budget each
well in normal times is about
70 million dollars a year that's based
on our
annual depreciation expense so that we
can keep our buildings up the way they
should be kept up
we have had to we've cut that in half
because
cash preservation in times of covid so
um anyway i gave you more information
that you needed than you needed but we
have our capital appropriation
hb 25 is as was adopted two years ago
and i i think it's highly unlikely any
of that could be diverted toward
consolidation
combination expense i didn't know if
there happened to be
any um uh technology
money in the capital budget for the
university
that was no that was mostly the focus of
my question
okay i'm going to ask
shannon to speak about the capital
budget for the community college system
please
sure so ccs says ccsnh is not on that
multi-biennium kind of funding plan
that usnh is the kathy just described so
we're talking about just the present
biennium we had
initially requested 16.8 million dollars
in capital funds
in the governor's budget there's about
2.5 million there's
one project for 2.5 million which is
actually the phase two continuation of a
project that was started
that was funded last in the last
biennium
so the the bulk of that capital request
is currently not
funded our top priority
in any capital budget is critical
maintenance and
um that is you know the things that we
have roofs and systems and boilers and
all the all that type of infrastructure
that needs to be
needs to be upgraded or is is that ends
of life or that sort of thing
that's not currently in the capital
budget we do have funds
requested for it but i don't think it's
a type of it projects that can
accomplish the kind of um kind of
bridging of the systems that kathy and
susan were talking about it's really
again
equipment that's at end of life um i i
don't see it necessarily translating
into
into the kind of um synergistic work
that we're doing um with the university
system
and then there's some other requests
that have to do with renovating
and upgrading labs um and other spaces
to kind of
serve the needs of industry pathway
programs in the
in the sciences and technology um so we
will be
working with the house public works
committee to try to get some of that
funding built back in again
i also know that there may be
opportunities from
federal dollars coming into the state
that might be um
might be able to be used for the the
type of one-time investment that capital
projects
often are so we'll have our eye on that
as well
uh shannon on the uh the perkins grants
um what kind of money does
the community college system get from
perkins grant
i don't have i don't have that figure
susan is that something that you
you know or we could bring it back to
the committee if none of us here
we could bring it back to the committee
it's a it's a small amount of money
uh most of that money goes to the
ctes and so a lot of the activity that
we do is in support of the efforts that
the ctes are making
uh with those funds okay yeah just if
yeah if you would when you know it's uh
i just didn't know
whether or not there was uh specific
money
at the community college level for
uh perkins grants that you could be used
to do
whatever you do there there
there is uh money um it's used in
the technical trade areas pretty heavily
also
in support of healthcare careers
and and it also provides money to do
professional development work between
the community college faculty and the
high school faculty
and finally it helps to support we have
other funding as well
the women and technology days that we
sponsor so that we get
women into situations to you know try
their hand quite literally at things
that maybe they haven't contemplated
as career paths in automotive technology
in in welding
and hvac and so on
uh my next question is that um i
understand that
this conversation about merger has been
occurring for a while
and i just wondered if um
you could tell us what your
two board of trustees have been
been doing in in that area
i can i can start um
i think our board started having a
conversation about this last
june and uh
adopted a resolution to have
a small group of trustees
reach out to the community college some
trustees at the community college system
and start talking about more
collaboration
and and that was the genesis of the
working group that susan mentioned
earlier
the um i also serve on that working
group and we've been meeting
bi-weekly now we meet monthly i think
it's since last june
and then our board had another
conversation in
october really supporting the concept of
consolidation and wrote a letter to the
governor to that effect
but then put it aside and said you know
okay this is our position
and we're not you know we have enough of
our
own university system work to do and
um so that's the
our board has been talking about this
for a number of months
and uh on the community college side
a little different story um
usnh board uh did send members and
approach members of our board
and um the conversation was very
cautious on our side as it continues to
be
and um our recommendation
by the time it took us a while frankly
to get to a place where
um we wanted to talk at length with the
university system about this and so our
recommendation
to them was that we would like to engage
a study and the message that came back
to the trustees was we've moved on
we're busy and so frankly at that point
the community
college system continued to do the work
that it was doing and it's only been
since around christmas that this
conversation has intensified for us
because when we've been
you know asked our opinion and and said
you know we need more information before
we can go forward
and that's based on not a desire not to
change
but because we can see what's happening
in other states
within my background when i came in 2010
i came out of 20 years in the
connecticut system
and if you follow any of this
information you know that
that system has been trying to affect
emerges since 2011
and it's been painful and played out in
the papers in the legislature and so on
so you know does that color my personal
view
yes but we we did go ahead anyway at the
time that the conversation happened
and we asked for uh and champs the
report was
you know that we gave you a link to to
to just fill us
in tell us about this that you know what
was it we need to
needed to be thinking about and how this
played out in other places
so we had taken that step but then it
appeared
through informal conversations as if
because we hadn't expressed
the level of enthusiasm that others had
that the conversation had
stopped so um we were a bit surprised to
hear it come back
up it is still um a significant
conversation
within our board because we have so many
questions
about how this would happen and i i
applaud our board because we have people
who are
tremendously devoted to our students and
businesses and so on who you know we we
would just like
more information as this is going
forward
and you know a conversation a comment
i've made other places
when we look at the other merges that
have happened
the first voice that goes away is the
voice of the community colleges
so you can understand why we have a
concern here
our work is necessary but it is not
glamorous
work you know we are supporting people
who are leaving us
in in many cases going out to work and
that may be
a six-week program a 12-week program a
year and so on so our
you know i support the university system
i am not a product of this
state's university system but obviously
having gotten a phd i support
higher education and i appreciate the
mission of the university system in the
four-year colleges
um we we understand that we want to give
our people opportunities
uh in in in my land we want people to be
able to start off we want an lna
to be able to do you know the eight-week
program
and aspire to be an lpn and an rn and an
aprn
and and you know in a d a dpn whatever
that pathway is that the student wants
we want to
uh play a a role in it in an efficient
and effective way
connect so so um
and i will say the university system
agrees a hundred percent and i think
the position of our board and i agree is
this is about the future of public
higher education in the granite state
and with all due respect
higher education is changing at a rate
that
that we can't keep up with and we need
to be looking
forward not in my opinion not
backward and
i will also say that we are a small
state
and so while this would be a big system
when you compare it to the size of other
systems in our country
it will still be a small system
and we should consider
lessons learned in the past in other
states
but it is higher education is changing
at a rate that what happened in another
state
10 years ago may not at all be relevant
to how new hampshire could move forward
improving public higher education for
all granite staters
in the next decade or 20 years or 30
years
so okay
um shannon i i have not had an
opportunity
to read your thing that you sent
us on was that on the merger business
and
what was going on there i sent you two
things
um that i thought would be helpful one
is the
chronicle an article that was published
in the chronicle of higher education
just this week that
reported on this merger proposal and
kind of give it give a little bit it was
a short article a little bit of context
about the proposal and then a bit of
national
context on on these same types of
conversations elsewhere because for
the very same reasons they're they're
coming up in other states two and a half
and then the second thing i said it was
much longer and that's the report
that chancellor heward referred to that
looked at a few other states did a kind
of a deep dive into the experiences a
few
of a few other states to outline you
know what were some of the initial goals
of those mergers or consolidations um
how what
what what drove those goals was it
demographics was it finance was it
student pathways you know what kind of
combinations of things um
what were the some of the steps taken as
these institutions looked at merging and
consolidating
how did they go what were some of the
major pain points
um in the in those processes what were
some of the successes
um that could you know early wins
longer-term wins you know
just kind of a a fairly thorough report
on
those three examples that we just
thought would be useful that was the
first
piece of research that ccsnh really
looked at um
starting last fall when you know it
looked as if this conversation
you know was something that we all ought
to be having
all right well i will uh i will read
those
hopefully soon and um because i
i think it's important that all of us
take a look at um
the uh the study that was done
to to see what what was going on and
uh and um you know
see if it you know as we go forward
hopefully to um prevent us from falling
down those same rabbit holes if that's
the right term
and i do agree that um
it would be easy for the community
college system to get
subsumed into the um
into the university system and
uh i am a strong proponent of that not
happening
so this is
this is where i know the governor
is was talking about
legislative action and that it seemed to
me
he wanted the two
or he wanted the board to become
um fully engaged in
that decision and
so i don't know um
if we want to think about
adjusting some of the legislation in hb2
this year
or if we simply want to say
uh we anticipate
you know this information being provided
to us
by november um
and it you know i i think that that's a
that's a choice that i would like the
community college and the university
system to make
because as you are as you are going
forward
with the selection of the five people
for example each of you have
requirements for who can serve on your
board
and so um and i think the governor
suggested that he expected the boards to
be fully engaged in this whole
transition and so um
i know that you know maybe maybe we
would make
the wrong decision but you can always
ask forgiveness if
if we have to change some people out i
mean that's that's
that's okay um but i i would like
some feedback not not today on that but
in the next uh
in the next couple of uh you know early
sometime mid next week or whatever
because we're gonna be whatever we do
we're gonna have to
we don't have a lot of time so
kathy i see that you can i um i just
want to be super clear on what
you'd like feedback on the process that
the
board would take to
[Music]
recommend five people or you'd like
which i'm sorry that we just need to be
clear on what
we what you need from us by early next
week
yeah what i'm what i'm looking for is if
you know thinking about the fact that
this is going to go
forward how would we
take the current board with all of the
restrictions that you have
on your membership and we obviously
would have to change that in the
legislation
this year because or waive it
or something so that
the uh the new this new board
that supposedly will take effect uh
one july can operate
over the next however long you want it
to operate
i know that's probably very confusing
but does
house bill 2 repeal
the part of our law that that names
our existing board yeah that might be a
good question
for matt if he could but i thought we
were essentially the new board
would take the place of both boards
effective july 1
based on our understanding of the
proposal
that is correct tom the idea and this
language is included in hb2
and i'm sure once hb2 is released from
ols
it'll be illustrated for the committee
as well
um but the legacy boards if you would
would each appoint five members the
governor would appoint
five members giving us a 15-member
new board that has governance over both
systems as they exist today
and that is all language you'll see in
house bill 2.
and i believe it addresses the other
points of the existing
boards for the existing systems um
but again once hb2 is out i think that
would probably be the best time to
go into the finer details of that
process
matt ma manager may i ask a question of
matt
certainly thank you um just to clarify
the legacy boards would a point would
each appoint
five members and that would be those
would be the five or those five but then
go through a different
um an additional process to be confirmed
i believe they are brought forward um
for i believe governor and
council approval but again i'd rather
hp2 language
be published and then go into this
conversation if we can
um
if that's okay shannon
of course we're just hopefully
hopefully hb2 will be out very shortly
if uh
representative weiler signed off on it
earlier today
okay so um anyhow
like i said i'm probably very confused
about this
uh as to how you know how this
um appointment is going to go
because your both of your boards
currently have um
restrictions for example uh
the unh board you have to appoint
somebody that's an alumni
okay yeah or maybe maybe two or three
people that are alumni
that's right i don't remember what it is
and over
on the community college side you have
to appoint people that
are working in the fields that you are
providing
degrees for uh technical things for
so there may be some um
there may be some things for this first
board
if that's the right term that don't
necessarily meet the requirements
of of what you currently have
but there may be people on your boards
that would be uh that would have
expertise to help with this
um all the things we've talked about
in in trying to unite but i certainly
would not want to lose off the
off this combined board uh
at least one and maybe two people
that are um with the technical side of
of um your current board
because i think that that is uh their
voice
probably needs to be heard
very loud in in whatever whatever
occurs and i guess the final thing is is
that i
and then i'll go to ken the final thing
that
uh i certainly understood from the
governor today
is he is expecting the boards
to be the lead the board to be the
leader
of this movement okay not the followers
but rather the leaders and i think he
said he wants people to understand
that if they are appointed to this new
board
that it is not once a month meeting but
rather
the impetus for uh going forward so
that i think needs to be fully
understood
by the boards so that um
it will those are the kinds of people
that will initially
uh be on the board and we also could
think about
do we want currently the terms i think
are
four years you know would we want to
um think about
maybe shortening the term
you know because you can't have
if i don't know if let's say that
somehow or other you appointed five
people
that all their terms all expired the
same year
from the from the old board well that
would not be a good idea
but on the other hand those may be
the five people that are most qualified
to be
on the board and so
that's something i think that we would
have to um
you know put in legislation that says
you know the this new board
will start out with fresh terms if
that's
the right statement you know that so
we're going to stagger them over
you know the time but again these are
things that that we need to
come to grips with as to what do we want
to put
in hb2 what's there
um i won't comment on since matthew is
sitting on the
panel but uh no i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding
uh ken you had a question i'm sorry to
ramble on for so long
yeah i just wanted to say that you know
what we're what we're confronted with
now we have a budget that shows
separate appropriations for both
systems i support that i don't want to
combine them yet
and as i look at hp2 i think it's moving
a little fast
and i wouldn't want to lose these two
great chances we have now
by doing something suddenly and then
suddenly
somebody that's that's done a good job
of leading their system
suddenly is is that position eliminated
i think it's too soon to
see that i prefer my my real job
representative i know you do
being the vice chancellor finance and
now you're really the real chancellor
i've seen you do great work so have a
lot of faith in you always have my
i always have your back so anyway
and uh and i don't want to move too fast
yeah susan is trying to retire
in uh she's tried to retire before but
yeah but i know my success
rate not so good in the retirement area
but yeah
and uh i've been uh needling her just a
little bit about
uh staying on and so anyhow but
you know those are the whatever
yes someone else we could leave hb1
alone
and do something in hb2 to change make
it a little longer term
maybe make it six months or a year
before this joint board
shows up uh i think you'll get a lot of
pushback on that
well um anyhow talk to the people that
are
going to be affected yeah yeah did you
have a question
yes ma'am cheer thank you so much i
really am
my concerns are enormous about the
timeline
i agree that the university system and
community colleges
the potential there is huge but right
now
just listening to the conversation about
the board
and that doesn't even take into
consideration the major
major effort of combining these two
entities
into a single moving healthy
organization
and i too want to do it right and i too
am
completely committed to both agencies
but we can't mess around and we don't
want to do a bad
job and muck up the good things we have
so i think we need to move cautiously
but most of all
if we're gonna do a system like this
then we have to invest
some quality people and some quality
dollars
so that people aren't trying to do this
half-wittedly
because i think it's important that it's
done right you know i watch snoo
and i watch what they developed you know
any one day they have about a hundred
and eighty thousand kids taking at least
one course
online and i know the investment that
they put in
i worked on part of it we've got to do
this and we've got to do it right
otherwise we're going to do more harm
than we're going to do good so that's
just a note of caution from me
um just you know formerly working in a
state system
in a private system it takes a lot of
work and we want to do it right and
without doing that effort
i think we'll do more harm than good so
i just really
i i listened to susan and i i've
listened to kathy
and i respect both of you enormously
but do you have time in your busy day to
devote
to making this system ready to go in a
year
my question i guess it depends upon
whether i retire
or not marry
um i do think it's going to take a level
of expertise i think one of the things
that you can hear
is that kathy's skills and my skills
complement one another
i'm very fortunate to have both shannon
and scott
on the legislative side and on the
finance side
my strengths are on the academic side on
the student services side
on the transfer side and so on so it is
we are going to need humans to to do the
work
um we're depending upon you to make a
good
decision for us you know you can hear
clearly that both systems
here that something needs to happen um
and and we support that but we support
it in in different ways we
we uh the community college wants to
continue to be nimble
through and through this is uh that's
our spirit i'm going to go off subject
for a second and
and tell representative umberger that
the community college system receives 1
million
or did last year in perkins funding
thank you representatives i would say
that
um at least
again this is from my vantage point
there there is no way that all the
processes and everything else could be
accomplished in a year
um you know i i don't know that it would
take 10 years
i think this this idea of the one year
is really about getting the legislation
right
frankly because making one new board
effective this summer
still results in two separate systems in
state law
okay so then this board
with legislative input i'm guessing
governors the input
then comes back and sees if there's a
sponsor
and then again just think it right
thinking through this then the
legislature has the next
year to contemplate what the combined
system would look like in state statute
because
combining the boards in and of itself
doesn't make one system
you still have rsa 187a and 188f
so the legislature has another whole
session year to consider
getting this right okay then if you
think through the time
okay now we're at june 30 of 22
when you have in law one system
then we have to start thinking about
okay what has to happen we have to
have technology we have to have faculty
and staff involved what's the financial
aid
so i think the point
though is if we don't start now
it will be 23 24 before we start really
thinking about
what can what's possible for public
higher education in new hampshire
uh let me just say this
i had nothing to do one night last week
and and so i decided to read
what the current law is for um
what is 187 and 180
whatever doesn't matter and
the the two
the two sections of the law
read very much the same
about the only thing that
confused me was it appeared in the law
that the trustees of the universe
university system
also have to run the water and sewer
system for dover
now i i i have no idea if that's
durham durham that's right i mean durham
is that a true statement um yes
we share the cost but we have the water
treatment facility in
on the unh campus that serves the whole
town of durham
okay thank you i had no clue
but maybe we can get rid of that
i don't know um unless unless we have
some uh
uh courses or a degree in uh
in uh whatever you call that sanitation
water and water water and sewer i mean
there's that
i'm i don't mean to sound critical of it
they are very vital vital things as tom
knows but when i went through and looked
at them
they were almost identical
in in what the responsibilities
of the two systems were that's because
when the community college system broke
off
from state government copy them the
statute
that the enabling legislation for the
university system was used as a model
for the community college system the
other thing i would say
and as you can imagine i've been
overthinking this for for
a few weeks now and
if if again i'm speaking for myself
if if we as a state are going to take
that on
wouldn't we start with rather than
what's
existing in state law that's been
amended for
uh you know 100 years what should it
look like
if i was going to build a system today
what does the law what should the law
look like rather than
mashing up the two that are there i
so and and i think that
to try to do that in this budget session
with a few months left will not
give it the thoughtfulness deliberative
process that it deserves
i don't i don't disagree with that um
but what i want to make sure is
that what hb2 says
allows the flexibility that's necessary
to override anything that is in current
law
and from my
knowledge of what it says i'm not sure
that it does that
you got muted i'm sorry representative
go ahead yeah you know one of the things
i guess that i
that that strikes me is here is that
we have a we have a sort of a very basic
fundamental decision to make and that is
do we want to do this or not and it
seems to me that
that decision um we are in a position to
make relatively quickly for example
we could say i would seem to me that we
could easily say
this new board is created as of july 1
uh 2021 and it will
operate the university of new hampshire
system pursuant to rsa whatever it is
and it will operate because the the uh
community college system pursuant to uh
uh whatever the statute is for that and
then you know i completely understand
that the details of getting
of of getting it all together is
is something that you're not going to
accomplish by july 1. i have no
question about that but it does sort of
seem to me that
the most fundamental part of this is is
putting the people in charge
of running the whole thing now it may
take them some time to make this into a
really integrated
system and i completely understand that
and i'm sure there will be
you know um problems along the way but i
i guess i i do tend to agree with miss
provencher that
we you know the we
we ought to we ought to do this we ought
to make that first that basic decision
and once we've made it we ought to at
least take that
sort of initial step that that would be
my take on this
i yeah uh
representative bucha
yes uh oh um um
how does the how does the fact that the
university system was founded as a
land-grant university gonna
gonna play into this
or will it i i don't think it's going to
play into it at all it's still going to
be a land grant
i mean the way the governor spoke about
we're still going to have ins in
individual
institutions in one system there are
we're a system now with four
with four in you know separate colleges
or universities
i i don't think it does affect the land
grant i i might be
speaking out a term but i don't think it
does affect the land grant at all
thank you as i told you
when i was uh wide awake reading all
this stuff
um if i understood correctly
the current thompson school is
what uh continues to qualify
the university system as a land-grant
college
and that in the course offerings that
they have there
um but that's how i that's how i read
what was
in the uh rsas at this point
so um the thompson school
to the best of my knowledge isn't going
anyplace
and so um i i don't think that that's
uh any kind of an issue at all tom
representative weiler
i just thought of something that
may play into this whole thing years ago
we were
trying to get a prison psychiatrist
and they couldn't nobody could nobody
would take the job
and we went into a contract with
dartmouth college to provide for mental
health services and so
they got a psychiatrist to do the job
but he wasn't he didn't have to put in
his resume that he was a prison
psychiatrist he put in his resume that
he was an
adjunct professor for dartmouth college
so
maybe once this whole system comes
together
and the community college is having
trouble recruiting teachers
rather than be part-time teacher for new
hampshire
technical institute they could be
adjunct professor
of the university system in new
hampshire it might it might
appeal to more people that you're
looking to hire i don't know just
something i thought might be one
advantage
that this whole thing could work out
thank you
okay are there any further questions
today
um yeah i know i know i've got
i've got a thousand but i'm not sure
that i can articulate them
um very well but um
i ask you to think about this read the
two things that
um shannon put together
and uh kathy if you have anything from
the university
that anybody can uh you know would be
find other research that's gone on about
the combination
of uh the university systems
with the uh technical systems and see
what
uh what that is um
i i know in new york
that they have
the college university system and they
have
the i don't know if they call it
community colleges or
what they're what they're calling it
today and i'm not sure
whether that when they created
uh the suny business
if they in fact integrated those two
systems or if they are still
completely separate systems but maybe
somebody knows
yes susan go ahead i was actually in the
suny system for 10 years
you can tell how old i am um i was at
the
in the community colleges and the suny
system
is 36 entities some of which are
community colleges
some of which are two-year schools that
are the last two years and then the
university colleges in the university
system
and um they're
loosely connected i was very interested
in what i think was representative lynn
had to say because
in that system there's a chancellor for
the entire system but then there is a
a ceo if you will for the community
colleges and then
and one for the university
parts so they do ultimately come
together
and that has assisted with transfer
issues for example um
they didn't go the route that florida
has gone with is actually a legislative
office for transfer
but it it does create a vehicle so that
the two systems have an effective way of
talking to one another
um but they're funded so very
differently the community colleges
are 30 tuition 30 percent from the
county
and then 30 from what we then called
suny central
so is there legislation
that created this do you know or
did it just happen i oh by the way you
don't you think you're old
let me tell you i was uh i was part of
the
initial sunni uh
integration i guess as a college student
so
wow um okay uh i'll cede my position to
you represent thank you
i have a degree from suny newport oh
very good
very good and i was at finger lakes um
i don't know about the legislation i'm
sorry
okay uh mickey maybe you could check on
that and see if you can
find anything
yep we can uh we can maybe touch base
with ols research to see if they have
any um
information already if not we can track
something down
maybe uh maybe ncls might have something
to
yep okay if there's nothing else for
today
um we will see you all on
monday at 10 o'clock
when we will um be taught our
agenda is hb1 hb2
and um i'm also uh
planning to have mickey talk to us about
the um uh
the highway fund the general fund the
education fund
fish and game all of those things that
uh that we have to uh that
that will help us as we are trying to
make decisions
about the budget so that's uh
that's what i'm looking forward to on
monday and i'm sure all of you
are and by the way any of you are
welcome to join us
not not
but if you would like
um we can
probably uh shannon and tom
let you know when we're going to be
talking about what it says in hb2
on the university system so that you can
you can join us for that look
at hb2 uh and hopefully
we'll all have it before monday at 10
but
we'll see okay so have a nice weekend
oh i'm sorry catherine i i really wanted
to
to thank you representative umberger and
the rest of division two
you have devoted an enormous amount of
time to the community college system in
the university system and we
very much appreciate the time so thank
you very much
thank you thank you quite welcome and uh
oh
by the way we haven't finished so we'll
we'll be talking to all of you again
shortly so have a nice weekend it's
supposed to snow tomorrow
but enjoy it anyhow take care thank you